guys let's talk about Emanuel Lasker
he's one of my favorite players one of
my favorite thinkers because he was not
just a chess player he was a
mathematician he was a philosopher he
really put into words the age of Stein
it's in a way that was just so fun and
interesting in his manual of chess I
remember reading that and being
entranced by how he wrote about the game
and spoke about the game and he was
really the first person who modernized
chess from a psychological standpoint as
well
I actually thought of him as a chess
psychologist I never thought of it that
way until I started studying his games
that people were saying he purposely
purposefully played second-rate moves to
induce a position that you didn't like
that incredible it sounds like a poker
player it was a bit of a chess hustler
in fact but that's the whole point
that's where the chess hustle comes in
because I always was thinking you got to
play the best move you always play the
best move of the position requires right
Jen you gonna play the best move how
aware you have to be to say no I'm gonna
purposely play the second-class moves
I'm gonna play this to get you in a
position that's gonna make you
uncomfortable but it was it was really
about also understanding your opponent
that's that's it wasn't what it wasn't
necessarily the quality of the move that
he cared about as much as the fact that
he was saying who are you
do you like while positions well right
quiet you like quiet position well then
if it's worse for me as long as you're
uncomfortable that's where I'm gonna go
that's a lot of the psychology in chess
competent in that openings and choosing
your openings and you know as a poker
player it's something people ask me all
the time do chess players have towels
can you trick them right and that I
think it is something that you can go
back to Lasker and say the chest poker
player well that's where he especially
from me brought it in and then Bobby
Fischer later even Garry Kasparov and
Carlton Magnus Maggie
that but that's that's jumping ahead
yeah we're sorry we're done yet this guy
Laska was very very special and he was
what the longest reign reigning world
champion well he did dominate for a long
time he had some some crushing match oh
yes yes we talked about a Frank Marshall
or poor Frank game player getting beat
eight zip okay there were some drawers
in there but you don't want to gain the
same thing to Janowski and crushed him
too yeah eight zip and so you realized
this guy was tough now he did have some
struggling matches well at least one
against Lecter yeah where that was a tie
and he got to retaining his title still
everybody he played he be beat Irish as
well yeah in there match up yeah and it
was a 27 year reign is that right yeah
that's that's absolutely incredible when
you hear that number 27
yes um do you think ok greatest of all
time no I don't because it goes back to
the idea that he wasn't forced to accept
matches there wasn't a structure it was
still all about you want to play me you
want to play me you got to go and raise
money and I'll tell you if I'll accept
your challenge the age of the private
world championship stage and you got to
raise the money all right I don't even
have to play the best Challenger I can
play the guy who came up with the money
exactly I want to play jet you know Jen
go out there oh no Jen stock trade you
know you raised the dough right and I'll
accept that challenge so yeah that's why
as much as I do respect and admire man
you Alaska can't say he's not in your
top three no well yeah so of course that
was a part of it and also World War one
was a part of it as well a mean rule at
a point that stopped a lot of chess
activity absolute players but now for
one player a guy named Jose Raul
Capablanca who had already started
showing the signs of being one of the
best ever so talented beat his father as
a little native this I just absolute
genius especially in his simplicity and
those in games exactly so he comes from
obviously from Cuba goes to school in
New York really doesn't want to study he
goes to New York and plays chess
and he does something that's simply
magical it's almost like Mozart he just
had this innate unbelievable gift he was
just a chess playing machine and the
logic of his play the style of his play
the Elan the elegance
doesn't lose for eight years no doesn't
lose a game for eight years that's
insane
yeah comes easy to him and I think he's
the kappa blanka is a player that is
very frequently named as a favorite
among world champions why do you think
that is it's not just not just the games
but also the personal charisma
well I wouldn't even go there so much as
the idea that everybody loves the moves
the moves themselves they speak for
themselves you look at it move the kappa
blanka plays and then the sequence that
comes after and you go right that's it
that that that that's the right moves
and then you you're proud that you're
aware that he played all the good moves
which of course opens that up to the
whole alexander alekhine and that right
well first of all he goes on to beat
last oh and that was another world
championship for zero no wins no wins
for last goodbye that time of course was
aged but still cup of Blanco was the
Machine and you know the thing is about
that match is Alaska resigned it without
even completing it exactly I suppose
like this Havana is too hot that's the
whole point
yeah and secondly this guy's was beating
me down I got no chance quit that man he
didn't even want to play in the
beginning it was very very reluctant he
obviously Havana was the worst choice
for him anywhere cooler climate would
have been better but I mean that was
where the money was and then speaking of
money Alekhine has to raise his money
takes a while for him to finally do and
the invincible
invincible loses to this guy nobody saw
that come nobody saw that coming
that's pretty incredible pretty
remarkable when you look at even the
history of the World Championships it's
such a clear favorite ended up losing
right so this was 1924 the greatest
tournaments ever takes place in New York
City kappa blanka wins it in this walk
in the park just strolls down memory
lane just beats the field badly and
Alekhine says please please please
mister world champion play me a match
and kappa blanka says if you can get the
money
10k well in gold it was I think it was a
very high amount well over a million
dollars in gold
yeah in gold which was kind of hard to
get to begin with okay just the gold
part so he made it very difficult and by
1927 somehow someway he's got this
chance in Buenos Aires and this is just
perfect for kappa blanka because now
he's in a spanish-speaking country the
ladies love him
they adore him Alekhine comes up with
the goods plays brilliant plays one of
the epic matches this is great
when when the the modern age really
explodes on chess is watching those two
because they hyper modern age I come
about as well and the world champions
the World Championships saw being full
of these kind of interesting because
they played a lot of Queens gambit
declined every game exactly
but then the modern age really strikes
then rye and alikom becomes champ and
the level of their players extraordinary
high and so of course the modern age had
arrived and these guys showed what true
epic chess was about that was indeed one
of the great ones